[Musique]
quelle leçon de fer que le rythme parce
que c'est inné ou ça s'apprend et ça
s'apprend y en a que c'est un don mais
halak aussi ça s'apprend mais a fait un
plaisir de faire cette expérience alors
peu importe où qu'est ce qu'il veut
qu'est ce qui vous permet en jouant tout
est possible parce que vous avez appris
par vous même dans les rues de dakar au
sénégal c'est comme ça que j'ai pensé ou
et bien sûr parce que comme on sait pas
si organiser ça comme ici il n'ya pas
vraiment décolle donc tu apprends dans
la rue tu joues des baptêmes des
mariages de serre au moins une idée
toutes sortes d'événements donc est ce
que vous vous souvenez le moment quel
âge avait sens ce grand coup de coeur
pour le djembé pour les percussions et à
partir je dirais à partir de 8 9 ans que
ça commençait parce que mon premier
spectacle je le fais à cet âge là
lorsque je me cachais pas ce que je
pouvais par les part bien sûr voulait
que je me concentre sur les études mais
moi je vous ai tous confrontés sur la
sur l'art quand j'avais la musique
j'aimais découvrir et aller voir le
spectacle donc c'est ça qui a gagné la
dernière fois qu'on s'est rencontrés
c'était pour le lancement du dernier
disque de richard séguin
vous m'avez dit à l'époque au sénégal
vous écoutiez du richard séguin tout
jeune et c'est comme ça vous avez
peut-être eu l'idée de vous rendre au
québec c'est heureux parce que c'est le
moment là que j'ai commencé dans comme à
écouter la musique tous assurent
toujours une envie joue bien il y avait
des chars syriens qui était venu au
sénégal dont je devais avoir 8 me voir
quelque chose comme ça et et c'est le
premier canadien je pourrai dire que
j'ai connu et j'ai vu à la télé et c'est
drôle parce que je me suis souvenu
quand je suis revenu au québec bien
quand j'ai eu la chance de venir au
canada
j'ai entendu à la radio j'ai du belge je
connaissais ce gala je connais cette
chanson là parce qu'il n'y a jamais
entendu jean 10 heures avant
jouer est arrivé au québec en 1996 deux
ans plus tard vous avez co écrit la
chanson pensez-vous de la wii avec des
départs de chansons des colocs yumi d'où
vous est venue l'inspiration pour
leicester le texte b c'est parce que
nous on faisait un démon de percussions
et c'est là qu'un ami nous a présenté
des des mois en été les frères juifs et
que bon sur notre projet que dd c'était
le technicien ne sont qu on connaissait
pas du tout on savait pas qu est-ce qui
il faisait ce qui lui donc lui était
super content de ça parce que je voulais
pas qu'on sache qu'il est donc il a
embarqué dans le projet il est vraiment
venu nous s'intéresser à ce qu'on
faisait et c'est quoi tout ça donc il
était en amour de notre projet et dans
ce cas là c'est l'axé qui a décidé de
nous inviter sur la chanson que nous a
expliqué qu est-ce qui chantait c'est
quoi le texte tend donc là avec leurs
frais de violence et c'est venu comme ça
c'est comme avec leur la collaboration
je suis très content de vous rencontrer
parce que j'ai adoré votre troisième
album outils coûts et de quoi vous
vouliez parler route du causse et c'est
la vie blc c'est une quête outils causé
le c'est comme si j'avais un sac avec
moi c'est un tee shirt sac d'expérience
que je traverse
j'ai parlé les frontières avec si ça
pour moi la vie c'est d'apprendre vers
l'autre aller vers l'autre et de toute
l'expérience qu'on voit c'est la quête
de deux choses qui nous marque qui fait
qu'on avance et qu'on sent que notre vie
aie du sens donc c'est syndicaux
il ya un thème qui revient toujours
c'est la résilience le courage pourquoi
parce que si tu peux pas accepter qui tu
es beau tu viens qui ou tu t'en vas peut
pas avancer tu te poses sur tourner en
rond tu va tourner en rond mais tout le
long en pensant que tu avoir recruté
toujours sur la même place donc ça fait
que je pense que cela le désir d'aller
de l'avant c'est d'accepter qui on est
et qu'est ce qu'on est et après par la
suite j'ai pensé c'est ça facilite
beaucoup les décisions moi même quand on
me demande si ça va je sais que ça va
pas des foires comme ne sait pas
toujours des matches comme on dit donc
je veux que ça aille bien
c'est ça s'est passé comme je me lève
même si ça allait mal je vois que ça et
bien et que je pense c'est quelque chose
que d'aller positif après peu importe qu
est ce qui est arrivé aux enchères
élage diouf je n'ai aucun sens du rythme
oui vous au moins en nous quittant m'a
donné un seul conseil
ah oui dommage parce que on a tout temps
tout le monde peut jouer tout le monde
peut pas chanter c'est tout
il faut juste pratiqués pour juste
commencer par le premier note souvent
qu'on est désolé c'est comme ça ça peut
être un bon début car il faut prendre le
temps que de pratiquer élage diouf je
vais pratiquer merci beaucoup merci à
vous
[Rires]